as russia's invasion of ukraine rages
millions of refugees are seeking safety
outside the country european countries
are welcoming them so far but how many
ukrainians can they receive and could
this signal a new migration policy this
is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hasam seeker the russian invasion of
ukraine is in its third week with no
sign of a let up the united nations is
warning the humanitarian crisis could
grow and affect millions more
the united nations high commissioner for
refugees says more than two million
people have now fled the fighting it's
been described as europe's worst refugee
crisis since world war ii
people are crossing to neighboring
countries to the west such as romania
slovakia hungary and moldova but most of
ukraine's refugees are in poland the
government there has said
to host them all it will need more money
than the eu is offering another 235 000
people have gone to other european
countries
well the conflict in ukraine is
affecting large numbers of children as
well according to unicef more than a
million ukrainian refugees are minors
many are unaccompanied either separated
from their parents or sent away by those
forced to stay behind the un has warned
that unaccompanied children are at
greater risk of suffering violence and
abuse
it's urged host countries to ensure
their safety
let's bring in our guests now from the
border town of shemesh matthew
in poland matthew saltmarsh is the head
of news and media for the united nations
high commissioner for refugees
from mexico city we have camille
lacazette senior
policy analyst at migration policy and
joining us from oxford in the uk
alexander betts a professor of forced
migration and international affairs at
oxford university he's also an author of
wealth of refugees how displaced people
can build economies good to have you all
with us so
matthew saltmash let me start with you
um
how how bad is the situation where where
you are right now we're talking about a
total of two million
uh people who have fled in the space of
of two weeks um just talk to us about
the current conditions there for
ukrainians and the biggest challenges
they're facing
well as you said uh the numbers are now
quite comfortably over two million and
poland in particular has been
very generous and
there's about 1.4 million refugees who
have come to this country and
significant numbers in those other
countries around the region
but also importantly um increasing
numbers who have moved on to western
europe following this implementation or
agreement at least of of this temporary
protection status
here today in shemesh it's a little bit
quieter than it has been in previous
days
um we're not entirely sure why that is
but one of the factors could be the fact
that it's been very cold up the border
which is just
10 or so miles away from me and so that
may have dissuaded people from
from trying to cross
obviously it's hard to say exactly how
the trends will go that very much
depends on
the conflict and how that evolves within
the country but the immediate needs are
obviously
food shelter
warmth
medical attention
the polls here have been trying to take
that away from the border area
and they're following a model whereby
they will offer
sort of full state security state
services if you like to those who decide
to stay here so they will get
accommodation they'll get
medical support and they'll get
education so that that's just the kind
of policy that we uh we would advocate
and we we warmly welcome what they've
done so far
and what is it that ordinary people can
do to to to help ukrainians uh beyond
beyond governments and and government
policy and
financial uh assistance from from from
the people that you've seen there and
and and the biggest needs for them right
now
there's been this great outpouring of
sympathy uh throughout europe over this
what what can peop what can ordinary
europeans do
well here in poland in particular the
local ngos local humanitarians have come
out on mass
they've gone up to the border to help
with information
to help with transport you see them at
the train stations providing water
providing support
and providing
information that they'll need to decide
where they're going to go next
in terms of the public at large in
europe
i think initially we would probably say
the financial side is important there
are a number of appeals more money will
be needed those appeals will increase so
that's very important and the public as
you said have been incredibly generous
so far
as refugees increasingly move perhaps to
the west to other countries
there are other things that people can
do they'll be volunteering
helping with education translation again
fund-raising
just helping refugees to really find
their feet and integrate in those
societies because
unfortunately
this is not going to be very short-term
it is going to be a bit longer we think
indeed uh camille lacaze uh matthew
mentioned there at the beginning that
this
eu temporary protection directive which
is uh which has been activated now it
wasn't activated back in 2015 during the
refugee crisis there uh when we saw
people coming from escaping the war in
syria and iraq and afghanistan why is
that why is it being activated now
so i i think first a bit of background
on this temporary protection directive
because it was adopted after the wars in
the bakken in the 90s
with this idea that yeah the eu should
have a mechanism in case of another
large flows of refugees um and as matt
mentioned you know as a result of its
activation last week uh for peop people
fleeing the war in ukraine have no
access to a range of rights residency
right right to work right to education
housing social welfare
and these are the same rights for all eu
members date
um and a key factor in this decision is
that it avoid creating another massive
backlog in the european [ __ ] system
as several european officials i've said
in the past week it's cut the red tape
and in a way it's saved national aslim
system from being completely
completely overwhelmed
and as you mentioned there have been
discussion in the past to trigger this
directive um in 2011 after the rap
spring into a 1516. um but for us
observer of eu migration and aslan
policy it felt like it would never been
activated it's been a bit forgotten and
yet last week eu member state came
together um even the one like poland and
ingary that have repeatedly
opposed hosted refugee and solidarity
across the eu
and they agreed that they needed this
mechanism to respond to what looks like
um
one of the largest displacement crisis
since world war ii in europe
alexander betts um just more broadly
speaking what do you think of the
political implications of all this this
influx of refugees that we've seen
uh from ukraine just in the in in the
last two weeks and and and what it
reveals about
about europe the response that we've
seen
i think we should celebrate the great
solidarity we've seen across europe
towards ukrainian refugees it's been
fantastic to see signs of commitment
empathy solidarity
everyday humanitarian response across
poland at railway stations that's
something that's been very important
i think of course behind that this isn't
the type of response we see to all
refugees in europe it's not the type of
response that we saw towards syrian
refugees or afghan refugees and equally
we see significant selectivity so
african refugees seeking to come across
the central mediterranean often face
drowning detention deportation so i
suppose the hope is that this moment of
solidarity public support for refugees
can be carried across to other refugee
populations i think one of the
challenges is that while the
humanitarian response in the short term
has been very strong the longer term
challenge will be can we make this a
sustainable response can we provide the
support that's needed to frontline
countries like poland hungary moldova so
that they can sustain um hosting
refugees for the medium to long term can
they get access to
financial support to buttress their
public services healthcare education
will be put under significant pressure
and housing for instance and can we
create a viable relocation scheme that
europe has very rarely been able to
agree upon to relocate some refugees
from those countries across the 27 eu
member states or beyond so i think
there's going to be questions about how
we can make the sustainable how we can
plan for the medium to long term but i
think there's hope there's hope that
this could be a moment where the
european union gets its refugee and
asylum policies right can build in some
of the opportunities for reform that
were missed in the aftermath of the
2015-16 crisis
uh yeah let's put some of that to to
matthew then i mean this this
sustainability issue is is a major one
isn't it i mean many many of the
ukraines the ukrainians that have
arrived there they may be getting basic
shelter uh and housing and food for now
for the the next couple of weeks perhaps
but what about the next two months but
what what happens beyond then
yeah i mean let's be honest uh no
government in the region three weeks ago
would have anticipated this
huge scale of human movement across
borders
um of course
people were aware of the tensions but i
don't think anyone was ready for for
this scale
and as i said earlier the governments
have really stepped up in each of those
countries they're leading that response
i think as things evolve and the weeks
go on they are looking
beyond the the immediate government
they're looking to the eu of course for
funds they're looking to the united
nations and they're looking to other
ngos and international ngos to come in
with expertise specialists who can
support in areas like like child support
education
and livelihoods
and then to
obviously to try and raise more money
which would be which will be extremely
important
we've put out an appeal other other
parts of the united nations have put out
appeals
and obviously the needs financially and
in terms of expertise
uh are going to be absolutely enormous
they are already but they're they're
only going to grow
camille lacaze we mentioned at the top
there this is this is the worst refugee
crisis that europe has seen since the
second world war what implications is
this going to have for overall policy
towards migration is is this going to is
this going to force a fundamental
rethink
i think it's really really too early to
stay and um well alex mentioned oh but i
think there's really a specificity to
this crisis that's that also explain why
countries like angry and poland um have
been more welcoming to refugees um from
you know to people fleeing ukraine uh
compared to previous crisis and and you
know we really see a different in the
response um at the polish border
compared to what we've seen just a few
months ago and at the border with
belarus with people and you know refugee
coming from afghanistan and
syria um
or iraq and there is what the response
was and i think the specificity of this
crisis is that this um this is a war in
europe and so in a way um there is no
other way for european government but to
respond um and to develop this you know
to set up this mechanism
um this is also a war that's a result of
an aggression from from russia and i
think for countries like poland it
cannot bring back some some painful
memories and it reactivates um somehow
this need for
um for european unity and that we've
seen um in the past weeks
and then lastly is this perception maybe
that these refugees are different and
again the support that we've seen from
poland and that has so far seen 1.4
million of people fleeing from ukraine
um is very different from
the very you know drastic
response that we'd seen at the belarus
border just just six months before
um
alexander best talk a little bit more
about the differences that you that
you're seeing in how
countries have
responded to this i mean obviously
poland has has taken the brunt of this
in in the short term uh as far as the
number of uh ukrainians that they've
taken in
but um i mean what about the ones that
are not sort of pulling their weight so
to speak
yeah we need responsibility sharing
across europe and this has been one of
the challenges faced historically by the
common european asylum system that
responsibility has been allocated
through the so-called dublin system to
the frontline countries so
in the
2015-16 crisis
greece was a front-line country and
other frontline countries like hungary
took a very restrictive view building a
razor wire fence trying to present
access to their territory now what we've
needed to do and what the european
commission has recognized is that we
need to update that system to ensure
that there's more consistent
responsibility sharing cooperation
across the eu 27 member states now this
is a moment to put that to the test to
recognize that for this to be
sustainable the responsibility can't lie
exclusively with poland and the visagrad
countries that we need to relocate both
people and share money that it will take
significant resourcing to support public
services to build jobs and livelihoods
opportunities
one of the positive things is we've got
learnings that we can take from the
aftermath of 2015-16
germany in particular which took the
overwhelming majority of syrian refugees
arriving in europe provided huge
investment to vocational training
employment integration that took time to
pay off but over time has seen more and
more syrians enter labour markets in
germany and integrate socioeconomically
if we can learn from that and have a
relocation scheme
and financial support and viable
opportunities to improve public services
employment opportunities not only for
ukrainian refugees but also local host
communities in the areas most effective
we've got the best possible chance to
have cooperation across europe but also
ensure crucially that local receiving
communities are still as responsive
enthusiastic and committed to refugee
rights in one year two years three years
as they are today
yeah um uh alexander brings up a big
point a good point there uh camille
about about the germany uh model in in
2015
2016 they took they took so many of the
refugees from from syria i think it was
over a million of them and they've
managed to integrate them into into
german society so this can be done can't
it
yeah and i think here it's really
critical to avoid the perception that
european
government are losing control and we
know this has been a major shortcoming
in 2015-16
and this could define whether you know
all this popular support that we see now
continue in the next months um and that
you know
and i think here a key question and
that's also a lesson from um from 2 15
16 and something that germany has been a
leader on is how do we make sure that
this right to work this access to
employment is is effective
um and so
again a lot of tools have been deployed
in term of you know credential
recognition that we're seeing
reactivated now and while we're all
focused on the operational response you
know the emergency um and you know the
the
make make this our instrument that has
never been used before in europe work we
need to be thinking about this medium to
long-term consideration because that's
something maybe that in 2015-16 we
didn't think about early enough
um
matthew so much i mean as i mentioned
there uh
so many so many people coming in such a
short time um are you getting a sense
now uh at all that that um uh
the the various authorities are are
getting a handle on this or could you
expect it to continue to get worse
it's very difficult to say right now
obviously that depends on events in
ukraine and the intensification there
but in terms of the government response
we think it it has been exemplary of
course
you know there there are there is going
to be an element of chaos when you're
dealing with this this scale of movement
but if you look at the case of poland
you've already got the offers of housing
we're starting to roll out very soon uh
cash assistance for refugees here in
poland and then that will go into other
countries working with some other
partners as well
and they're talking about
vocational and medical training
recognition of qualifications for
ukrainians and i think that's important
because it helps the host country as
well
um there may have been something of a
labor loss or a brain drain in poland in
particular in the last five or ten years
so going back to that example of germany
this could also be an opportunity for
poland to reskill
um and to get a lot of that talent
that's come over from ukraine
unfortunately if you look at it from the
other side
it leaves the country of ukraine in a
very difficult position because
uh so much of that talent and that
workforce and young people
will have will have come across and of
course uh the male population at the
moment as you know are engaged in combat
uh camille lacaze what um
what implications is this going to have
for for asylum policy going forward
yeah i think i yeah i think it's early
it's too early to say and again i i
think a key um a key factor is going to
be how um perceive this this response is
um i think one thing i wanted to add
also is um you know we've talked about
this the activation of this mechanism
the temperature protection directive
and what we're seeing on the ground is
the need to register people very quickly
um with this mechanism that
was never used before and that has
involved setting up specific
registration system for people you know
who are comings and um also relying on
new mechanisms that have been set up
since 2015 and 16 such as the eu asleem
agencies that's not really helping out
um the countries that need to do this
registration
so i think in a way um we're seeing a
lot of lesson learned on how to do
better that's that we've done in the
past um and hopefully this can have
implication um for you know eu islam and
migration policy in europe but i really
think we need to um understand that this
is a specific crisis compared to
other situations that europe has faced
in the past past decade
yeah what's what's your view on that uh
alexander betts this is
that this is something very specific and
the the whole issue of whether there
needs to be a broader policy changes is
something perhaps a bit more further
into the future
i mean i think europe has needed to
change its policy response to asylum
immigration for a long time and this
might be the catalyst for that change i
think there is obviously something
unique about this context of conflict on
the borders of europe but we have seen
moments in the past that parallel this
as we've already heard during the 1990s
with the conflicts in bosnia and kosovo
we saw mass influx situations into
europe and they were the moments that
triggered significant innovation in
european asylum systems they created the
temporary protection directive in 2001
for instance that is now being invoked
as we've heard for the first time since
its creation so i think it's through
moments like this that we recognize the
need to update that human displacement
is going to be one of the defining
challenges of the 21st century that we
live in an increasingly insecure world
and that we have to have national and
regional and global systems that are
adapted to that reality so i think we
shouldn't necessarily see this as as
just a one-off it is possible that we
will have other major drivers of
displacement including to europe and we
need to ensure that we prepare for now
respond to the immediate crisis but also
have systems of responsibility sharing
that can endure i think it's also
important to recognize that regions can
learn from one another so dealing with
mass influx situations is something that
regions beyond europe have a lot of
experience with
um in africa for instance there have
been large-scale responses to movements
of south sudanese refugees somali
refugees that involved
supporting public services supporting
livelihoods and employment creation for
both refugees and host communities and
very recently in latin america the
venezuela situation is one we can learn
from colombia has taken in similar
numbers of refugees to those in poland
and it very quickly provided them access
to public services a temporary status um
the right to work and so i think there's
a lot of learning that can take place
and this is a moment where we can update
uh our european refugee response
hopefully not only for this situation
but others in future
matthew saltmarsh what are some of the
uh logistical challenges perhaps that
your organization has has been
encountering uh communication
uh down there if that's been difficult
at all what what what are some of those
challenges
well obviously inside ukraine there are
huge logistical challenges we've just
started in recent days to move convoys
of aid
across the border into the western part
of the country and then trying to get
that out into the more conflict affected
areas
the teams that we have there have been
trying to get out when they can it's not
always of course been safe to do so and
they're trying to start with uh
monitoring so to locate where internally
displaced people are set up shelter
structures and then bring the basic
support through to them
on this side of the border i think the
challenge in the first week was the
sheer scale of arrivals
people obviously were passing through
structures weren't
put up in advance of that
and
a number of people were just moving on
without being traced or without
perhaps the authorities knowing where
they're going so
trying to bring in a little bit of
order into that you mentioned children
and child protections are trying to
bring in more specialists and get in
place those important
steps that are needed in terms of
identity identification and tracing and
so on um
yeah so so that's the focus really for
now
we're gonna have to leave it there
thanks very much to all three of you
matthew saltmash camille lacaze and
alexander best thanks very much for
being on inside story thank you as
always for watching remember you can see
this program again anytime just go to
our website aljazeera.com and for more
discussion go to our facebook page
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle there is at aj
inside story for me hasn't seeker and
the whole team here bye for now
[Music]